el fatal disparo ocurrió en un conocido
lugar de rodaje mientras el equipo
estaba en el set los reportes indican
que el actor y productor alec baldwin
disparó accidentalmente una pistola de
utilería matando a la directora de
fotografía salina hudgins e hiriendo
gravemente al director joel show de la
policía todavía está investigando las
circunstancias exactas en su nombre el
portavoz de alec baldwin dijo que se
produjo un error en el disparo de un
arma con balas de fogueo la víctima era
una profesional respetada que fue
nombrada estrella emergente de la
industria del cine por american
cinematographers en 2019 el equipo
estaba filmando la película rast en el
rancho bonanza creek donde se han hecho
decenas de películas alrededor de las 2
de la tarde la policía recibió una
llamada del 911 y llegó al lugar hudgins
tenía 42 años y fue trasladada por aire
al hospital de la universidad de nuevo
méxico donde murió